Der Weiße Zwerg mit der Bezeichnung SDSS
J1228+1040 ist nicht allein!
Ein britisches Forschungsteam hat jetzt ein
bis zu 600 Kilometer großes Objekt entdeckt,
das die Sternleiche in rund zwei Stunden umläuft.
Extrem und extrem seltsam.
Was kann das ein?
Ein Planet ist es nicht.
Höchstwahrscheinlich besteht es aus Metall
und es ist enormen Gezeitenkräfte ausgesetzt!
Was passiert da?
Clixoom Science & Fiction - Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich
willkommen!
“White dwarfs” - also Weiße Zwerge, sind
quasi Stern-Leichen, die sich am Ende der
Entwicklung von Sternen bilden.
Auch, wenn sie etwa so groß sind wie die
Erde, vereinigen sie eine gesamte Sonnenmasse
in sich.
Anfangs beträgt ihre Oberflächentemperatur
unglaubliche 10.000 bis 100.000 Kelvin.
Also irgendwas zwischen rund 9.700 Grad Celsius
und 99.700 Grad Celsius.
WOW!
Doch weil sie über keine zusätzliche Energiequelle
mehr verfügen, kühlen sie langsam aus und
enden als Schwarze Zwerge.
Das passiert innerhalb von vielen Milliarden
Jahren.
Solch ein Weißer Zwerg befindet sich auch
im Sternbild Löwe.
Seine offizielle Bezeichnung lautet “SDSS
J1228 + 1040”.
Auch er hat etwa die Größe der Erde und
vereint 70 Prozent der Sonnenmasse.
Aufgefallen war er dem britischen Forschungsteam,
weil sein Spektrum bei den Analysen die Emissionslinien
von Kalzium offenbarte.
Die Fachleute beobachten den Weißen Zwerg
schon seit 15 Jahren, unter anderem mit dem
Teleskop “Gran Telescopio Canarias” auf
der Kanareninsel La Palma.
Sein Spiegeldurchmesser beträgt 10,4 Meter.
Und die Arbeit hat sich gelohnt, denn jetzt
steht fest:: Der Weiße Zwerg ist nicht alleine.
Die Experten haben mit Hilfe von spektralen
Analysen einen Begleiter der Sternleiche dingfest
gemacht.
Es handelt sich um ein Objekt, das bis zu
600 Kilometer groß ist, den Weißen Zwerg
mit einem Abstand von nur einer halben Million
Kilometer in rund zwei Stunden umläuft, also
nicht 365 Tagen, wie es zum Beispiel bei unserer
Erde der Fall ist.
In kosmischen Dimensionen ist diese Distanz
quasi nichts und so wirken gigantische Gezeitenkräfte
auf ihn ein.
Nach Angaben des Forschungsteams kann es sich
deswegen nur um ein äußerst metall reiches
massives Objekt handelt, das diesen Gezeitenkräften
überhaupt stand halten kann.
Denn normalerweise müsste jedes Objekt, dass
sich einem Weißen Zwerg so nähert, auseinandergerissen
werden!
Zum Vergleich: Wenn es sich bei der Konstellation
um unser Sonnensystem handeln, würde sich
der Begleiter innerhalb der Sonnenoberfläche
bewegen!
Fest steht jedenfalls, dass die Strahlung
des Weißen Zwerges das Objekt so sehr aufheizt,
das Material verdampft.
So bildet sich ein gelber Schweif - WOW!
Doch wobei handelt es sich bei dem Begleiter?!
Die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
vermuten, dass es sich um einen Planeten-Rest
handelt.
Konkret könnte es der metallische Kern eines
ehemals größeren Fels-Planeten sein.
Dem Forschungsteam zufolge könnte dieser
bei der Entwicklung seines Zentralgestirns
zum Weißen Zwerg zerstört worden sein.
Heißt also im Klartext: Der Weiße Zwerg
hat die äußeren felsigen Schichten weggerissen,
sodass nur noch der metallische Kern überblieb.
Spannend ist vor allem das Verfahren, das
die Forschungsgruppe angewandt hatte, um den
Begleiter überhaupt erst aufspüren zu können.
Denn direkt sichtbar ist er aufgrund seiner
direkten Nähe zu dem Weißen Zwerg nicht.
Was erschwerend hinzu kommt: Von der Erde
aus gesehen läuft er nicht vor dem Zentralgestirn.
So könnte man ihm also auch durch eine immer
wiederkehrende Verdunklung aufspüren.
Und so halfen sich die Fachleute mit einer
Spektral-Analyse.
Hier konnten sie rätselhafte periodische
Verschiebungen der Kalzium-Emissionslinien
beobachten.
Genau genommen ging es hier um die sogenannte
Akkretionsscheibe, die dafür sorgt, dass
immerzu Material auf die Oberfläche des Weißen
Zwergs herunter geht.
Diese Akkretionsscheibe rotiert charakteristischerweise
um ein zentrales Objekt und transportiert
- also akkreditiert - Materie in Richtung
des Zentrums.
Nur, weil also immer neues Material nachströmt,
ist dieses überhaupt erst im Spektrum sichtbar.
Denn solche schweren Elemente sinken aufgrund
der Schwerkraft direkt ins Innere der Sternleiche.
Die rätselhaften spektralen Verschiebungen,
die das das Forschungsteam beobachtet hatte,
können der aktuellen Studie zufolge einzig
und allein mit der Existenz eines Objektes
mit geringer Masse erklärt werden, das den
Weißen Zwerg umläuft.
Das nun erstmalig angewandte Verfahren hat
großes Potential.
Denn es könnte Astrophysikern weltweit eine
große Hilfe dabei sein, weitere Begleiter
von Weißen Zwergen zu entdecken.
Und so könnten dann auch weitere Rätsel
zum Schicksal von Planetensystemen gelöst
werden.
Es ist wirklich irre, was da draußen im Weltall
so alles passiert.
Vielleicht können ja zukünftige Generationen
ja dorthin reisen und solche Phänomene selbst
erforschen.
Das wäre ein phantastisches Zeitalter!
Und möglich wäre das vielleicht so: Generationenschiffe
| Leben und Sterben im All Draufklicken, anschauen
und Raumzeit - Vlog der Zukunft abonnieren!